W
SUIT.
>> Laura: BRANDON, THINK YOU
SO MUCH.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
WE HAVE ARKANSAS
SENATOR TOM COTTON WITH US
TONIGHT.
SENATOR, THE ISSUE OF CRIME AND
OUR UNDER INCARCERATION PROBLEM
HAS BEEN REALLY BIG ON YOUR LIST
TO ADDRESS IN THE U.S. SENATE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF WHAT WE ARE
SEEING TONIGHT WITH THE FACT IS
WE KNOW THEM TONIGHT?
>> LAURA, IT'S ANOTHER
HORRIFYING STRING OF CRIMES IN
MEMPHIS.
THE PEOPLE OF MEMPHIS DESERVE
MUCH BETTER THAN WHAT THEY'VE
GOT IN THEIR CITY GOVERNMENT.
IN THE LAST FEW DAYS.
REFLECTIVE OF CRIME GOING BACK A
LONG TIME.
EFFECTIVE OF CRIME IN BIG CITIES
ACROSS AMERICA.
I AM PRAYING LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
MEMPHIS OR IF THIS KILLER HAS
CROSS THE MISSISSIPPI REFER IN
ARKANSAS THAT THE BEEN ABLE TO
SWIFTLY APPREHEND HIM FOR A GOT
TO THIS POINT IN PART BECAUSE OF
FAILURES OF THE LEFT ACROSS
AMERICA TO TREAT CRIMINALS AS
THE CRIMINALS THEY ARE.
WE DO NOT HAVE AN OVER
INCARCERATION PROBLEM IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AS THE LEFT SAYS, ISN'T THIS
SOME REPUBLICANS SAY, HALF
OF ALL VIOLENT CRIMES GO
UNSOLVED.
TELL THEIR VICTIMS WE HAVE OVER
INCARCERATION PROBLEM.
KILLERS LIKE THE ONE WE SEE
TONIGHT ARE DEPRAVED SOCIOPATHS.
THEY NEED TO BE LOCKED UP OR
THEY NEED TO BE EXECUTED.
THAT'S THE WAY TO KEEP OUR
CITIZENS SAFE FROM THESE
CRIMINALS.
>> Laura: SENATOR,
SPEAKER PELOSI REVEALED WHAT HER
GOAL IS AFTER THE TERMS OF THE
DEMOCRATS MANAGED TO STAY IN
POWER.
WATCH THIS.
>> JUST PAST THE ASSAULT WEAPON
BAN IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
IF WE WENT TO MORE SENATORS WHO
SHARE OUR VIEW IN THIS NEXT
ELECTION, WILL BE ABLE TO PULL
BACK THE FILIBUSTER AND PASS THE
BACKGROUND CHECK LEGISLATION AND
AGAIN THE ASSAULT WEAPON BAN AND
MAKE THE WORLD SAFER.
>> Laura: SENATOR, THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IF PEOPLE
KEEP VOTING FOR DEMOCRATS.
INNOCENT AMERICANS WILL BE
DEPRIVED OF THEIR ABILITY AND OF
THEIR WEAPON OF CHOICE TO USE
FOR SELF-DEFENSE.
AND MORE DEPRAVED CRIMINALS WILL
BE RELEASED ONTO THE STREETS.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED HERE
TONIGHT.
THIS MAN SHOULD BE BEHIND BARS.
HE WAS LET OUT INTO YEARS
INSTEAD OF THREE.
THREE IS A JOKE FOR A SENTENCE
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
>> THINK ABOUT WHAT NANCY PELOSI
IS SAYING.
DEMOCRATS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
HAVE ELIMINATED THE BAIL SYSTEM.
THEY HAVE SHORTENED PRISON
SENTENCES.
THEY HAVE ELIMINATED THE DEATH
PENALTY.
THEY SYMPATHIZE WITH CRIMINALS
MORE THAN THEIR VICTIMS.
AND THEN WHEN YOU SEEK CRIME
RAMPAGES LIKE WE HAVE SEEN IN
MEMPHIS IN THE LAST FEW DAYS,
LIKE IN PHILADELPHIA.
WHAT IS THE DEMOCRATS' SOLUTION?
TAKE AWAY YOUR RIGHT AS A
LAW-ABIDING CITIZEN TO DEFEND
YOURSELF AND YOUR FAMILY.
LOOK AT JOHN FETTERMAN THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE FOR SENATE IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
HE SAID IF HE HAD A MAGIC WAND,
IF HE WOULD CHANGE ONE THING.
IT WOULDN'T BE THE COST OF
GASOLINE.
IT WOULD BE THE PRICING OF
GROCERIES.
IT WOULDN'T BE THE OPIOID CRISIS
THAT WE HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY.
IF JOHN FETTERMAN HAD A MAGIC
WAND, THE ONE THING HE WOULD DO
IS ELIMINATE LONG PRISON
SENTENCES FOR MURDERERS.
JOHN FETTERMAN IS NOT AN
OUTLIER.
HE MAY BE A RADICAL BUT ENTIRELY
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE RADICAL
LEFT IN AMERICA TODAY THAT HAS
UNLEASHED CRIME WAVE ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY.
YOU SAW IN THE CLIP WHEN
NANCY PELOSI SAYS HER ANSWER IS
TO BE DISARMING LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS.
THAT'S WHAT WHY EVERYONE OF YOUR
VIEWERS SHOULD VOTE REPUBLICAN
TO MAKE SURE WE CAN PROTECT OUR
FELLOW CITIZENS FROM THESE
DEPRAVED CRIMINALS.
>> Laura: SENATOR COTTON,
ANOTHER POINT THAT WE HAVE TO
RAISE HERE IS THE INJECTION OF
RACE INTO THE CRITICISM OF THE
POLICE WHICH WE SAW GOING BACK
TO AL SHARPTON, ECHOED BY ERIC
HOLDER IN 2014 WHERE IT WAS THE
FIRST INSTINCT OF THEIRS WAS TO
SAY IT'S RACIAL.
IF SOMEONE IS ARRESTED, IT'S
RACIAL.
IF SOMEONE IS MANHANDLED, IT'S
RACIST.
THAT'S ALSO I THINK COMPROMISED
POLICING ACROSS THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE YOU TALK TO THE POLICE.
THEY ARE AFRAID.
THEY ARE AFRAID TO DO ANYTHING
LEST THEY BE CALLED RACIST FOR
ARRESTING SOMEONE WHO'S NOT
COOPERATIVE.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO BE A
POLICE OFFICER IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT.
>> IT'S INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING
TO BE POLICE TODAY.
I TALKED TO POLICE OFFICERS ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND THEY
WORRY VERY MUCH THAT MIRRORS OR
COUNTY EXECUTIVES OR GOVERNORS
WILL NOT SUPPORT THEM WHEN IN
THE HEAT OF THE MOMENT, THEY
HAVE TO USE DEADLY FORCE.
THEY WANT ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
ANYONE WHO ACTS INAPPROPRIATELY
BUT THEY DON'T WANT POLITICIANS
JUMPING TO CONCLUSIONS AND
THROWING THEM UNDER THE BUS.
WE SHOULD BACK THE MEN AND WOMEN
IN BLUE.
THEY ARE THE ONLY THING THAT
STANDS BETWEEN YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY AND THESE CRIMINALS LIKE
YOU SEE TONIGHT AND THIS RAMPAGE
ACROSS THE CITY OF MEMPHIS.
IN FACT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST
HARMED BY THIS CRIME WAVE ARE
LIKELY TO BE MINORITIES.
MEMPHIS IS UP MAJORITY
AFRICAN AMERICAN CITY.
LOOK AT WHAT THEY HAD TO DEAL
WITH NOT JUST IN THE LAST FEW
DAYS BUT IN MONTHS AND YEARS OF
RISING CRIME.
THE SAME IS THE CASE IN SO MANY
CITIES ACROSS AMERICA.
THE DEMOCRATIC LEFT HAS FAILED
AFRICAN AMERICANS WHERE CRIME IS
RISING IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS.
THAT MAN THAT KILLED ELIZA
FLETCHER WAS APPARENTLY
TERRORIZING HIS OWN COMMUNITY.
THE APARTMENT BUILDING THAT HE
LIVED IN.
WHERE WERE THE POLICE OFFICERS?
BLACK, WHITE, LATINO OR ANY
OTHER RACE TO PROTECT THE
CITIZENS QUESTION LIKE THEY
DESERVE BETTER FROM THEIR
ELECTED LEADERS.
>> Laura: MEANWHILE WE HAVE
THESE CONSENT DECREES THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT STILL HAS AN
EFFECT ON POLICE DEPARTMENTS
ACROSS COUNTRY.
I'M NOT SAYING IT IS NEED TO BE
ANY REFORMS.
I'M SURE REFORMS ARE NECESSARY
IN SOME CASES.
THE FINDINGS OF IMPLICIT BIAS IN
POLICING, THOSE ARE TWO READILY
FOUND WITH VERY LITTLE EVIDENCE
AND SENATOR, BACK TO THE ERIC
HOLDER POINT.
I WOULD LIKE TO READ THIS QUOTE
SO PEOPLE KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
IN 2013 HE SAID "TOO MANY PEOPLE
GO TO TOO MANY PRISONS FOR FAR
TOO LONG FOR NO GOOD
LAW-ENFORCEMENT REASON.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
INCARCERATION IS USED TO PUNISH,
DETOUR, AND REHABILITATE, NOT
MERELY TO WAREHOUSE.
AND FORGET."
WELL, YOUR FINAL REACTION TO
THAT, SENATOR, GIVEN THE NEWS
TONIGHT?
>> WELL, I THINK MOST CITIZENS
IN MEMPHIS WHICH THIS KILLER HAD
SPENT MORE THAN JUST A FEW YEARS
IN JAIL FOR HIS CRIMES.
ELIZA FLETCHER AND HER FAMILY
WISH HER KILLER HAD SPENT MORE
TIME IN JAIL THAN YOU DID FOR
HIS HEINOUS CRIMES.
PRISON IS THERE NOT ONLY TO
PUNISH AND DETER BUT ALSO TO
INCAPACITATE.
AS YOU SUGGESTED, SOME PEOPLE
SIMPLY NEED TO BE LOCKED UP TO
GET THIS COUNTRY SAFE.
IF THEY ARE DEPRAVED MURDERERS,
THEY NEED TO BE EXECUTED.
SOMETHING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS REFUSED TO DO
FOR THE DAY THEY TOOK OFFICE
EVEN THOUGH THERE ARE STILL
FEDERAL PRISONERS SITTING ON
DEATH ROW, SOMETHING THE
DEMOCRATIC LEFT AND LEFT-WING
LEGAL --
>> Laura: THEY'RE GOING